[Musique]
parce que vous profitez de votre séjour
en france pour regarder le sen à la
télévision française non plus je ne veux
pas le débat qu ils n'avaient pas
entendu votre doigt française iran
[Musique]
parce que maintenant vous êtes
débarrassé de ce personnage est ce que
vous avez oublié le st oui j'ai oublié
or c'est mon agent vous pensez faire une
nouvelle série mauvaise nouvelle c'est
new series non pas le centre nous
faisons maintenant c'est qu'on dit on
pensait les amis swazi des amis j'ai
choisi avec tony kart wii
[Musique]
pourquoi avoir choisi tony curtis
pourquoi parce que nous aimons grandes
stars de cinéma
[Musique]
on
combien de fils on veut tourner vous 224
tous situés sur la côte d'azur
non non non tout le premier 6 nous
faisons l'espériez vole aussi
après nous avons en nombre pour faire
l'intérieur
nous sommes tous trois mois trois mois
après peut-être l'espagne
ici en suisse ou en italie
c'est pour la télévision britannique et
vous tournez pas tout moment cambrin
nos seins
y à 4,80 se portent 90e 90e télévision
qui n'ont en 96 80 pays y avait eu six
boules et vous espérez qui évidemment
quand sera autant pour cette nouvelle
série
j'espère
[Musique]